oh Jenny Craig c'était Adnan
Salif rural qui a mangé de l'aulne au laser pour faire court un
nouveau filet de la même manière que je ne suis pas Je ne suis pas un
porte-parole blanc de la communauté noire
Je n'ai pas de jour pour les hommes Je suis juste Je suis un
observateur  quand j'avais 16 17 ans j'ai traversé
une période de phase dans ma vie où je
voulais être de retour très désespérément pas
pour des raisons politiques pour des
raisons culturelles il y avait certaines choses que
je trouvais très belles et très
attirantes et plus tard j'ai trouvé un moyen
de  intégrer ça dans ma vie et être
un homme intermédiaire un homme marginal et puis
entre et c'est en fait beaucoup plus
intéressant mon premier ma première
figure masculine forte était mon beau-père c'était un
journalisme
un niveau de musique africaine mais la personne
qui a vraiment donné  moi j'étais une sorte de
héros pour moi ma première année j'étais un
nettoyeur d'appartement zoulou nous vivions et travaillions
au coin de la rue où je vivais il
était un guitariste danseur guerrier ainsi que le
nom était Charlie et Zillah c'était
le premier  m'a appris à jouer de la guitare
et  pour danser de son côté elle était juste
de son côté je rentrais de l'
école et je disparaissais le mardi
soir jeudi soir samedi et dimanche
je dansais et à tout autre moment
après l'école si je voyais des
musiciens de rue je disparaissais donc je  n'avait pas de
vie de famille normale en général parce que
mon beau-père était divorcé ma mère
vivait seule et j'étais l'homme de la
maison mais je n'étais jamais là je ne sais pas
si la culture juive avait quelque chose
à voir je ne pense pas mais  ma mère le
pense, mais je ne pense pas, je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup d'Afrikaans
en Afrique du Sud, des gens courageux qui se sont
levés contre l'apartheid qui parlent
des langues africaines et qui ont rejoint
la lutte pour démanteler l'apartheid, donc je
pense que tout est
dans  Une psyché africaine qui est intrinsèquement
brutale Je pense juste qu'on leur a
refusé la bonne expérience On m'a
accordé les droits ou une bonne
expérience c'est vraiment ce que j'ai
vécu en Afrique du Sud depuis l'âge de
se  Même jusqu'à l'âge d'environ neuf ans et je suis
allé dans une école réservée aux Blancs quand je suis allé
en Zambie, je suis allé dans une école non raciale
pendant deux ans, ce qui a été un choc pour moi
et ce fut la première
expérience de réalisation directe de la non-apartheid
ce qui a évidemment exagéré les esprits
de l'apartheid et puis quand je suis retourné
en Afrique du Sud quand je vivais, c'était
tout un choc de retourner dans le
blanc intérieur est l'école ségréguée blanche est
fondamentalement ce n'est pas une question d'
amant de [ __ ] vous savez que je pourrais  agissez comme la
culture italienne ou la culture esquimau ça n'a pas
vraiment d'importance c'est que j'ai trouvé une
maison dans une certaine culture n'importe qui
peut trouver une maison toutes les cultures sont humaines
et fondamentalement je vous savez je pense que
j'aime j'aime m'éloigner de  le noir et
le blanc que j'aime chez moi en Afrique du Sud je
parle juste de la culture humaine c'était un
très bon guitariste qui écrivait de la bonne musique
et donc je lui ai dit
je peux enregistrer ce que tu joues et il a
dit qu'est-ce que tu veux dire je  dit que j'ai un
m  une machine qui peut l'attraper prends ce que
tu joues et attrape et il a dit non
ce n'est pas vraiment le magnétophone facile
il n'avait jamais vu le magnétophone
avant donc je cite dans le magnétophone
et il a chanté et j'ai tapé enregistré la chanson a
commencé et  l'a appliqué en arrière et il a
sauté et il a dit qu'est-ce que c'est et j'ai
dit que c'est un enregistrement sur bande, vous savez que vous
pouvez voir le violon où puis-je en acheter un, j'ai
dit au magasin, donc je devrais vraiment
me laisser faire beaucoup le gars à l'intérieur du magnétophone
de chansons parce qu'il était vraiment
excité à ce sujet et puis il m'a dit de
venir chez lui la semaine prochaine et quand
je suis arrivé il était très fier d'avoir apporté
un magnétophone il avait enregistré la
chanson bonjour il m'a donné la cassette il a
dit qu'il y en avait  nouvelles chansons les
mouvements démocrates de masse l'ont rencontrée ainsi
que certains de nos partisans et ont
essentiellement essayé de la discipliner et de
la ramener dans le mouvement je pense
que tout attend en attendant le
procès car il n'y a pas eu de
tribunal c  mais c'est encore faux parce que
nous avons maintenant des preuves archéologiques de l'
exploitation minière au Transvaal, elle remonte à
6 700 ID, nous avons une autre usine en
Guinée fourrière, nous avons maintenant
des preuves archéologiques claires qu'ils ont
essayé de vivre là-bas il y a 1500 ans, donc
c'est incorrect,
vous savez sélectionner le Sud  L'
industrie africaine est la plus puissante d'Afrique
et évidemment elle emploie des
gens du Malawi Mozambique etc etc donc
clairement le niveau de production et
le niveau de vie du travail est supérieur
à l'ensemble de la zone sud-africaine je
ne sais pas je ne '  Je ne sais pas ce que je pense si
vous regardez la Côte d'Ivoire, nous pourrions
avoir un problème, je pense que peut-être pour le
katinhat, vous pourriez avoir un problème, je
ne sais pas, mais comme il y a une Amérique
différente,
je pense que le gouvernement du recyclage est conscient de
l'actuelle Victoria en  les médias sur
l'Europe de l'Est et les changements dramatiques
qui s'y produisent et
il veut surfer sur la vague d'optimisme pour
atténuer les changements qui ont eu lieu
et qui se produiront  e qui se déroulera se
déroulera dans une vie sociale il y a les
plages hôtels restaurants etc qui
ne met en aucun cas en danger le pouvoir et
n'implique pas de transfert de pouvoir transfert
de talent nous avons toujours l'
apartheid économique et nous avons toujours des
nominations politiques la question à  demander est le
suivant mon stagiaire peut ensuite aller à la plage mais
puis-je posséder un magasin sur la plage
mes déclarations et mes perceptions sont
entièrement les miennes je ne suis connecté à
personne aucune organisation ou aucune fête ou
aucun groupe de personnes c'est purement un
artiste  et activiste culturel qui
cherche et essaie de donner un sens
à ce qui se passe autour de lui.
le modèle dominant est
un homme, une voix aux États-Unis,
il existe un autre modèle de l'
Afrique du Sud fédérée et les nombreux
modèles différents qui circulent. Je
soutiens personnellement le premier, les
États-Unis.  Franchise universelle en Afrique du Sud
je pense qu'il est clair que les blancs
auront encore des positions très très très puissantes et
dominantes dans l'économie et
donc indirectement dans la politique donc
et l'ANC et d'autres
organisations noires sont conscientes que le
bannissement des blancs du Mozambique
du Zimbabwe  et d'autres pays ont été
dévastateurs pour ces pays et ils
sont très soucieux de garder les Blancs
là-bas,
l'exécutif de l'ANC est éclairé,
vous savez, c'est donc si nous parlons d'
une Afrique du Sud non raciale, je
pense que c'est important
c'est un  important le maître et l'
esclave sont liés dans une
dialectique négative très très intime